im november 2008 10 berichtet der
länderspiegel aus dem rheinland
pfälzischen niedererbach diese 300 meter
lange sackgasse sollte auf satte sechs
meter verbreitert werden samt neuer
kanalisation
es drohten bis zu 140000 euro
erschließungsbeiträge mittlerweile haben
bereits zwei anwohner ihre häuser
verkauft straßen habe nach der sendung
kommt plötzlich bewegung in den fall um
kosten zu senken soll die straße nur
noch fünf meter breit werden dann stellt
sich heraus helfen wird das den
anwohnern aber nicht denn im baugewerbe
sind die preise förmlich explodiert die
ausschreibung ist raus die kosten gehen
20 prozent wieder höher wenn wir ein
kleiner nachtrag kommt dann sind wir
teurer wie vorher
sobald die bescheide ankommen wollen
anwohner dagegen klagen
als wir vor sieben jahren aus dem
sächsischen waldenburg berichtet haben
gab es dort massive probleme mit dieser
kreuzung die auffahrt wurde völlig
falsch konstruiert laster haben sich
hier regelmäßig festgefahren
wenn das leiden schon sehen dass das
nicht funktionieren kann mir das fach
melanie merken können nach jahrelanger
planung hatte umbau nun endlich begonnen
die auffahrt wird ein meter angehoben
und an die fahrbahnseite kommt 117 meter
lange stützmauer stolze 27 millionen
kostet die korrektur der fehlplanung mal
sehen ob die lkw die mix besser die
kurve kriegen in geislingen an der
steige in baden württemberg haben sie
nicht die kurve bekommen
seit sommer 2008 zehn sind weiter teile
des michelberg gymnasiums gespart es
besteht lebensgefahr nach einer völlig
fehl geschlagenen sanierung die hat die
stadt satte 21 6 millionen gekostet
unter dem strich kann es nicht sein dass
man 20 millionen investiert und als kühl
als elternteil dass es noch schlimmer
ist wie zuvor unabhängige experten haben
das gebäude jetzt noch mal begutachtet
ergebnis die schäden sind weitaus größer
als bekannt
es gibt erhebliche mängel beim
brandschutz bei den technischen anlagen
also der heizungs und lüftungstechnik
der fassade von der stadt wollte uns
niemand ein interview geben schriftlich
heißt es das ist für uns alle ein schlag
ins gesicht
ursprünglich wollten wir noch in diesem
jahr mit dieser sanierung der sanierung
staaten nun brauchen wir einen neuen
masterplan wie es weitergeht weiß
niemand es droht sogar der abriss des
gymnasiums wer die verantwortung für das
desaster trägt müssen am ende wohl
gerichte klären
von einer lösung ist man im bahnhof in
grünstadt ebenfalls meilenweit entfernt
seit jahren sind die aufzüge immer
wieder defekt mühsam müssen kinderwagen
rollatoren und gepäck die treppen hoch
und runter geschleppt werden
ich sag's wie dramatisch die situation
ist erlebte jörg adam also den aufzug
benutzt bleibt er mittendrin stecken
es dauert fast anderthalb stunden bis
der herzkranke bahnkunde befreit wird
von der bahn hat sich bis jetzt niemand
bei ihm gemeldet also auf der bahn kann
überhaupt kein tschuldigung gar nichts
das wahrscheinlich dass bei denen normal
laut bahn wird sich der einbau der neuen
aufzüge weiter verzögern
wir werden die entwicklung in der pfalz
aufmerksam verfolgen
in görlitz dagegen haben sie eine lösung
gefunden
im oktober 2018 droht im stadtteil hagen
werber die stilllegung des
fußballplatzes der grund die stadt bekam
1,2 millionen euro fördermittel für die
sanierung des stadions der freundschaft
bedingung der intakte sportplatz in
hagenwerder gedicht gemacht ich find's
unter aller sau was hier mit uns gemacht
wird nach der sendung kommt man zur
besinnung und zu einem kompromiss die
isg hagenwerder darf den rasenplatz doch
weiter nutzen im gegenzug dürfen aber
keine gelder aus der sportplatz
förderung in die anlage fließen
wir haben bewiesen und hoffentlich haben
dass alle anderen auch gesehen wenn man
sich wehrt kann man was erreichen der
ball wieder rollen ein grund zu feiern
ende gut alles gut